[Music]
dude so Goblin mode what is that
you thought it was story worthy
apparently yeah because I posted I made
this video where I was on uh I was on
the subreddit like confessions okay
people confessing to [ __ ] yeah one of
the top most rated ones for the last
like year or month or whatever was this
one that was like sometimes when I'm
alone and there's no one home
I act like a goblin like I'll use a
pillowcase as my trinket sack and I'll
run around and grab [ __ ] that I already
own and be like I'll be having that and
I'll put it in my sack and I'll make
Goblin noises and so I looked up what a
goblin noise was and anyways it's like a
funny little bit and then I posted it
and all the comments were like oh no
this is like a there's a huge sub
community of people that like acting
like goblins it's called Goblin core
and and it's always this activity
specifically or they make Goblin sounds
yeah it was making me really sad so I
didn't want to like actually look into
it okay
but yeah that's why I said
because it's is it not sad
I don't know no do you just go in Goblin
mode I mean yeah I guess I go Goblin
mode yeah yeah and I gobble that [ __ ] up
yeah you gobble these nuts too but
no it's just like I don't know I was
just like I'm not I'm not going down
this Rabbit Hole I don't even know so
this was a video you made or you were
just looking into it kind of thing it
was on a video but it was a little part
of a video and it was like one of the
funny because I was acting like a goblin
people thought it was funny and then so
now that word Goblin core has been
officially added to the Webster's
Dictionary so tons of people were like
tagging me in those posts so what's the
official definition Goblin mode
or no is it Goblin motor Goblin core
that got added Goblin mode the slang
term is defined as a type of behavior
which is unapologetically self-indulgent
lazy slovenly or greedy typically in a
way that rejects social norms or
expectations I'm gonna go Goblin mode in
a bank
I'll be having that I will be having
that take the entire Federal Deposit for
the day the daily value or even rob a
bank now or is just all electronic I
worked in a bank for six months you
could Rob one like what would you what's
the max amount you could get out of it
yeah it's not much I think it's like I
think it's like Max like 750 to a mill
it's not really anything and it's pretty
much impossible to get away with
nowadays I would think
set no 752 a mill for robbing a bank is
pretty
I mean like that's enough for like
that's a good day four length liquid
length limb lengthening surgery yeah I
guess for the effort I'm saying it's not
you guys don't make me sound like a
psycho here did you guys see that uh art
installation that art basil that like
you swipe your ATM card and it puts up
your balance and there's a leaderboard
no you didn't see that that's crazy yeah
and it is the ultimate Flex I mean I
think that's the point it's like the
commentary on wealth or whatever the
[ __ ] that's the [ __ ] that's the
boxing punching machine for rich people
yeah exactly yeah and Diplo had a video
go viral because he walked up to him put
his ATM card in he had three million
dollars in his checking account sick and
so he was number one and I mean it was
kind of a weird video because it's like
it's like a weird why would you want to
flexible how many people like liquidate
their whole portfolio and put it into
like a checking account that's what I'm
saying like it's pretty risky to walk
around with three million dollars in an
uninsured checking account yeah dude
like also doesn't that make you super
robbable yeah I mean why would you
posted that was there an awesome dude
across the street looking through the
window like why would it not be insured
how do you know that because like most
checking and savings accounts no no not
three million dollars after two so what
do you do segregated over like 17 again
no put it in the market I don't know
that's not invested
yes uh uh brokerage account I don't know
yeah you can get a yeah up to like a
million I think or something like that
most brokerages do that I'm pretty sure
I would venture to say Diplo has enough
money that it can't all be insured
yeah I mean maybe but even then like
I don't know buy bonds or something no
dude keep it in your checking account
how the [ __ ] else three million dollars
cash yeah
you just keep it all in FDX that would
have been a smart move yeah yeah exactly
yeah dude you want to talk FTX drugs
yeah this is the video right here oh
let's see it let's see it
people are clapping
[Applause]
it's like a picture of the guy to go rob
yeah I know it's just so crazy man yeah
it's not nuts yeah [ __ ] steal my
identity please I think it's a I think
it's a good art piece definitely like
clearly the maker of this was like yeah
this shit's gonna happen people are
gonna clap like it's gonna be just
[ __ ] up yeah you know no that's that's
genius but
yeah hit Rob in a bank useless also when
you rob it now
I don't know if I'm supposed to say this
you know probably yeah I mean you're
sort of you're just instructed to give
the money
oh yeah well that I would say is fair if
you're like a especially like a minimum
wage employee or something yeah I would
be pretty pissed if they were like if we
get robbed you gotta fight the guy yeah
yeah you gotta risk your [ __ ] life
yeah yeah under no circumstance let them
take the cat yeah yeah dude
and what is kind of crazy though is when
when the truck pulls up to drop off the
cache there is one person who's like
technically responsible for that money
like you like sign a like you sign a
form when the money comes in you're like
oh yeah this million is technically in
my name no it's kind of crazy so if I if
they if it gets lost it's on me kind of
yeah like if something were to happen to
the money like they would point to you
first to be like okay what the [ __ ] you
know I don't know if you'd be blamed but
yeah like that's why like local branches
and stuff it kind of takes time to
become that person yeah have you uh seen
any of the new Jeremy fragrance content
dude I haven't kept up with him really
he's got he got like really skinny and
then [ __ ] and I was like this is scary
yeah some of his new videos are like
pretty unhinged doesn't give a [ __ ] but
they're hilarious yeah I mean he's still
funny yeah I don't know if he'd be able
to go to his Tick Tock but he does it's
funny because people come up to him that
are fans of him and the first thing he
does is he smells them to see what their
fragrance is so he'll like uh like even
an attractive chick come up to him and
immediately he's like
holy [ __ ] oh Jesus
but it's like for him that's like his
thing what a genius long con did you
ever see the like when I interviewed him
yeah YouTube yeah so like that call the
one that I forgot to record or like the
screen recording didn't work was like
one of the most insane calls I've ever
had with anyone in my entire life no he
uh messaged me once and he was like
obviously on one of his like Peak energy
bursts and he was like do a Natty or not
on me bro
he's like I only take creatine but [ __ ]
it there it's like I already know the
answer
yeah he's like yeah no I got it
I have to do it
I'm surprised that nobody brought out a
Nutella fragrance man
power this thing smelled so good it
smells better than every fragrance on
the market and smells better than every
food and tastes better than any food on
the market I love this but I don't eat
it
damn I wonder if he masturbated before
the video or not
there's one where he smells whey protein
you gotta find that one it's it's insane
let's analyze it I'm the number one
fragrance influenza I know how to do
fragrance and understand smell
oh yes yes
so good
no wonder they say that goat's milk is
the most similar to mother's milk it
smells so gorgeous but it is so calm
before this one like mentally yes
yes
that's me trying to [ __ ] hype myself
up to eat anything
for ice cream yeah
yeah oh more food yay